mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
three congruent circles are bound
together by an elastic band as shown
if each circle has a diameter equal to
one
what is the length of the elastic band
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to solve this problem we will connect
the centers of the three circles
the distance between two centers is
equal to the length of two radii
therefore the distance between two
centers is equal to one diameter
which is equal to one next
construct a line segment from the center
of the circle
to the elastic band do this
for each point of tangency
in total we will construct three
congruent rectangles
the short side of the rectangle has a
length equal to the radius of the circle
and the long side has a length equal to
two times the radius of the circle
which is equal to one we now will
consider
the length of the curved portion of the
elastic band
we have three curved portions that we
need to find the total length of
now in the center we have an equilateral
triangle
so each of these angles will be equal to
60 degrees
in the rectangle each angle will be
equal to 90 degrees
therefore the remaining angle must be
equal to 120 degrees
and that's the central angle of this
circular arc
all three of these arcs have the same
measure of 120 degrees
therefore we can put all three of these
arcs together
to form a circle this circle will have a
diameter that's equal to one
so its circumference will be equal to
two pi r
which is equal to pi we can now
calculate the length of the elastic band
it will be equal to the sum of the three
straight line segments
which have a total length equal to three
and
the curved line segments which have a
total length equal to pi
therefore the total length of the band
is equal to three
plus pi and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
[Music]
you